[Musique]
vous savez ça fait au moins cinquante
ans qu'on n'a pas vu autant de neige
dans les rues de moscou
qu'est ce que c'est que ces boîtes sur
michael
cette voiture si tu ne vaux le garde
avant c'était les membres du
gouvernement d'union soviétique qui
roulait avec
les ministres généraux diplomates et
maintenant tout le monde a le droit d'en
avoir une
et vous qu'est ce que vous faites en
russie j'ai envie de connaître la
création contemporaine à moscou j'ai
envie de voir les galeries les musées
ah
oui vous avez vraiment raison
moscou c'est une ville mystérieuse
intéressante
c'est un peu comme new york et jérusalem
oui c'est ça comme lady gaga reine quand
il est parti dans l'espace
on commence cette visite sur la moskova
dans ce brise-glace avec les bruits de
ces plaques de glace qui se brise
la promenade elle est particulièrement
appréciée par les habitants de la ville
ils viennent ici le week-end découvrir
leur ville leur fleuve
[Musique]
ça c'est vraiment une vue somptueuse du
kremlin bordée par la moss va pendant
très longtemps connaissait finalement
moscou qu'à travers le cinéma à travers
les films à qui était produit dans les
célèbres studios de cinéma mosfilm les
plus grands studios d'europe il existe
toujours aujourd'hui on tourne toujours
à des films pour la télévision le cinéma
on va y aller ensemble
[Musique]
non
plus discret que les studios d'hollywood
sur les hauteurs de la ville
l'histoire des studios de mosfilm se
confond avec celle du cinéma russe
bâti dans les années 20 c'est ici qu'ont
été tournées les plus grands
chefs-d'oeuvre du cinéma soviétique
eisenstein et tarkovski qui ont posé
leur caméra
vingt ans après l'effondrement du régime
soviétique
les studios russes doivent aujourd'hui
leur survie aux productions télé
mais ce matin au studio numéro 7 on
tourne un film historique
alexandra à 23 ans elle fait partie de
la toute jeune génération d'acteurs
venus
aujourd'hui elle est venue saluer sergei
un réalisateur avec qui elle espère
travailler un jour
vous vous souvenez de moi à oui on se
connaît non je suis alexandra vous êtes
venu à l'anme casting je crois
autres montagny c'est quoi déjà tu
faisais
vous avez déjà travaillé sur un film
comme celui-ci oui j'ai tourné dans deux
longs métrages non en fait 3
c'est très important pour moi de voir ça
parce que j'ai détourné que dans des
films contemporains
là c'est un film historique et c'est
vraiment très intéressant
mosfilm possède ses propres ateliers de
décoration et d'effets spéciaux mais
aussi sa propre collection de costumes
qui retrace toute l'histoire du cinéma
soviétique
parmi les centaines de milliers de
tenues conserver ici
alexandra veut nous montrer la robe de
son film culte l'un des rares films du
cinéma russe
récompensé à hollywood
de ce côté là ce sont des costumes connu
ils sont tous numérotés oui ils sont
tous étiquetés par là il ya beaucoup de
costumes célèbre
hall à regarder cette rave la bleue là
elle était portée dans un film très
connu une comédie de l'époque soviétique
qui raconte l'amitié de deux personnes
au travail c'est une comédie très
célèbre
et là à regarder un de nos réalisateurs
qui s'appelle vladimir menchov a reçu un
oscar pour son film moscou ne croit pas
aux larmes c'était en 1979 et c'est la
robe de l'une des actrices principales
c'est un de mes films préférés
ça c'est l'histoire du cinéma pour moi
je peux en essayer une wii mais c'est du
44 mais moi aussi je fais du 44 alors
c'est parfait
ok allons-y ah non pardon la robe de
mourir view va vous préférez l'autre oui
la roja
tout le monde se souvient de cette robe
dans ce film c'était vraiment la plus
belle
je vais l'essayer je reviens
[Musique]
ce n'était pas gagné
regardez
comment vous me trouvez
[Rires]
au fait c'est quoi la phrase la plus
connue de l'actrice du film tu te
rappelles dans le film dizaine l eau
comme toi
elle faisait comme sa
taille chez mars co artistes m'angoisse
le lendemain matin alexandra a rendez
vous dans le centre de moscou
il est vraiment trop tôt
mais heureusement ce n'est pas comme ça
tous les jours
ce matin je joue la petite fille d'un
personnage très important
elle a décroché un petit rôle auprès de
vladimir menchov le réalisateur de
moscou ne croit pas aux larmes justement
cette figure du cinéma russe est réputé
pour son mauvais caractère
le dia qui appelaient la au rck
aujourd'hui le réalisateur est devenu
acteur et héros d'une série policière ce
matin alexandra joue le rôle de la
petite fille de vladimir
certaines scènes sont longues mais elles
sont découpées dans tous les sens sa
compagne c'est très rare qu'on passe un
plan séquence
aujourd'hui je tourne des scènes très
courtes quelques minutes
a plus
ni moins de
20 ans
[Musique]
vladimir menchov fait partie de ces
artistes qui ont vécu la mutation de la
société soviétique
en 1981 quand l'amérique la oscarisée il
n'a pas été autorisé à venir chercher sa
statuette
pourtant il fait partie des nostalgiques
on sentait derrière nous un pays grand
effort c'est impossible de se retrouver
dans la situation actuelle où depuis
cinq ans on ne participe plus au
festival de berlin
on refuse aussi souvent nos films à
cannes et à venise
tout ça ça n'arrivait pas à l'époque de
l'union soviétique
voilà la situation actuelle de notre
cinémas les théâtres en revanche
produisent des spectacles intéressants
le théâtre ça va bien mieux il est plus
inspiré en ce moment que le cinéma
c'est là que se trouve certainement la
nouvelle génération d'acteurs et de
metteur en scène de demain
[Musique]
on compte 93 théâtre à moscou
au coeur des quartiers chics la scène la
plus prestigieuse de russie le bolchoï
le théâtre du bolchoï est en travaux
coup de jeune sur la façade de ce
célébrissime théâtre cool jeunes
également sur la programmation de ses
spectacles on n'hésite pas à confier à
de jeunes metteurs en scène les oeuvres
classiques du répertoire c'est le cas
d'une opérette de strauss elle a été
confiée à un jeune garçon vassili
baratte of découverte de ce mariage
réussi entre passé et présent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bolchoï l'heure est aux répétitions
[Musique]
vassili brad off est un jeune surdoué de
la mise en scène depuis un mois ils
montrent la chauve souris une opérette
viennoise du 19e
à seulement 26 ans va s'il a déjà monté
cinq opéras
[Musique]
m
pour sa première mise en scène dans ce
théâtre mythique le jeune vassili a
voulu entièrement revisité l'opérette de
strauss
l'action ne se passe plus à la sortie
d'un bal masqué mais au bord d'un
paquebot sur la mer baltique
la méta l'ancien joueur nous ont plein
d'idées toujours il son
énergie est ici justement voici l'essai
exactement quelqu'un qui a énormément
sur le détail on travaille vraiment
vraiment sûr sur chaque expression prévu
et c'est très très instable ne met pas
tremblé face à trotter
[Musique]
je
sa bouche d'égout sa retraire
[Musique]
venu acheter
c'est dit comment se passent les
répétitions
bien
je pense que tout se met en place c'est
pas un peu impressionnant de travailler
au bolchoï
pour moi si un peu
on est dans le plus célèbre théâtre de
rue si connue dans le monde entier
et à mon âge me retrouver à travailler
ici
c'est un miracle
seule concession à strauss
le livret est toujours chanté en
allemand comme à sa création à vienne
[Musique]
pour les costumes vassili bouscule aussi
les traditions
il a fait appel à la star montante de la
mode à moscou un jeune créateur nommé
igor chat pour in que tout le monde
s'arrache chapeau et paquebots oblige
chapeau rinne a dû concevoir des
costumes capable de résister aux membres
les marins porte cette tenue mais ils
sont en fait comme si on les avait
repêché en pleine mer
il enlève tous leurs vêtements jusqu'au
t-shirts et des méthodes sécher dans
leur cabine
jusqu'aux chaussures il faut qu'on voit
qu'ils sont trempés
les costumiers qui viennent du théâtre
sont très traditionnelle
chez moi parfois j'ai besoin de création
plus moderne avec des design qui
viennent de notre temps
je suis donc très content qu'igor est
accepté de collaborer avec moi
c'est la robe verte avec le turban blanc
elle portera les trois couleurs que tu
voulais blanc vert et noir et jaune
la prise de risque a toujours fait
partie de la mentalité russe à l'oscar
c'est nous qui avons inventé la roulette
russe
les russes croient au talent et au dos
et ils savent faire confiance et
rousquilles ou mais c'est un peu pour
elle
c'est pourquoi le fait que vassily
soient jeunes est un avantage pour mes
ruches est
peut-être jeunes dans l'art car la
jeunesse c'est l'absence de stéréotypes
c'est l'anti conformisme destinés à la
jeunesse elle n'a pas peur de prendre
[Musique]
c'est dans cette aile du bolchoï réservé
aux costumières qu'igor fait ses
premiers essayages
[Musique]
les comédiennes viennent de toute
l'europe pour travailler avec vassili
anna stéphanie la soprano et anglaise
les manches sont deux fois plus large
et là il y aura ruban ça tombe bien dans
le dos c'est très joli
igor est très à l'écouté il prend en
compte nos envies c'est la première fois
que je vois ça
c'est vraiment très appréciable
en plus ces créations sont belles trop
belle pour être porté que sur scène
bell chouette chouette le bolchoï c'est
le bolchoï
c'est une institution s'est mêlée devant
laquelle on s'incline ainsi que devant
tous ceux qui y travaillent
j'ai la chance de faire partie de ce
théâtre tchèque
[Musique]
au même moment sur la scène du bolchoï
on termine de monter le décor toute
l'imagination de vassili prend
brusquement forme
c'est une piscine qui sera rempli de
champagne puis une fontaine se mettra en
marche
et tous mes personnages la baronne le
chevalier commenceront à nager
s'éclabousser dans une piscine de
champagne et là je fais quelques
vérifications car il ya quelques détails
à régler
dans chaque hub l'eau on a placé des
écrans plasma
pour simuler la ligne de flottaison du
bateau
et symbolisé la limite entre la surface
et le milieu marin avec ces poissons
dans deux semaines je vais voir mon
opéra sur cette scène j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de chance d'être ici
d'ailleurs j'espère que la chance soit
toujours avec moi après la première
représentation
après strauss vassili envisage de venir
travailler en france où il rêve de
revisiter la belle au bois dormant
un peu
m
fin de journée l'heure où les théâtres
se remplissent et celle où la ville
s'embrase
elle
[Musique]
pour
oui
ans
mon
on
le lendemain rendez-vous sur les toits
de moscou avec jean-philippe un
architecte français
c'est pas facile d'arriver jusqu'à vous
jean philippe et non un peu on et j'ai
choisi l'animal bel hiver avec je
comprends pourquoi c'est magnifique
elle est très étendu cette ville ah
ouais les étendu sur plus de 80 km
dans tous les sens on compte tous 15
millions d'habitants est donc là on a
une espèce de panorama avec tous les
styles architecturaux de la ville depuis
plusieurs siècles là on a le kremlin le
coeur de la ville au coeur historique le
coeur politique politiques et religieux
y en a cette gratte ciel parsemé dans la
ville et servent de repères parce que la
ville et c'est quand même romo jeunes
sur les sept gratte ciel construits par
staline à la sortie de la guerre il ya
l'université de reno sauf deux
gratte-ciel
administratif des ministères de gratte
ciel qui sont des hôtels et deux autres
qui sont des immeubles d'habitation
d'habitation
celui ci dans le clocher magnifique et
culmine à 126 mètres toujours fini par
des flèches
là je vois d'autres gratte-ciel ajuste
au fonds beaucoup plus moderne on
appelle moscou citée
l'équivalent de la défense à paris je
vois qu'il ya pas mal du sinn le long de
la moskova ça c'est la marque la fin du
19ème les traits industrielle de moscou
on a commencé à construire
des centres industriels sur la rive
droite de moskova et celui ci notamment
qui l'immeuble des chaudières qui donc
chauffe la ville et notamment le kremlin
proximité
cette venue ici est déjà combien de
temps 17 ans et j'ai développé une
agence d'architecturé est ce que vous
avez eu un coup de coeur pour la ville
alors j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour la
ville et puis j'aime bien les
perspectives j'aime bien passer devant
le kremlin sur la place rouge on avait
des fuyante du hoggar synthèse cachent
de véritables palais souterrain
il est un des symboles des années 30 et
de la réaliste qui triomphait en union
soviétique à cette époque
à la station mahias callas marbre métal
et mosaïques décrit une société
communiste idéal
[Musique]
au delà de saboter le métro de moscou
est aussi l'un des plus utilisés au
monde après celui de tokyo 7 millions de
moscovites l'empruntent chaque jour
[Musique]
le métro est à lui seul un site culturel
et historique il a été construit dans
les années 1930 sous staline il a
mobilisé tout le pays l'armée rouge les
jeunesses communistes les hommes les
femmes les ouvriers et les artistes les
artistes vont mettre leur talent au
service de la propagande révolutionnaire
il faut nous montrer ici un tous les
héros de cette révolution bolchévique
les agricultrices les ouvriers mais
marin les parachutistes et évidemment il
y a la place pour les sportifs ce
footballeur muscler vos cette jeune
femme vaillante qui va bientôt lancer le
disque on veut encore sain et robuste on
est vraiment dans des sculptures qui
sont là pour idéaliser la société
soviétique à partir des années 30
[Musique]
et quand on est amoureux pour se porter
bonheur c'est sur l'un des ponts de la
ville que l'on vient déclarer son amour
[Musique]
c'est absolument incroyable des
centaines de cadenas sur tous ces arbres
avec des prénoms partout c'est comme ça
que les moscovites viennent se dire je
t'aime regardez sergei macha c'était il
ya quatre jours un immense camp rouge
pour se dire donc tout leur amour
[Musique]
c'est allé cette promenade et nous
emmène vers le musée pouchkine c'est une
autre institution du pays légendaire
pour ses collections aux
impressionnistes une maison dirigée
depuis plus de 50 ans par un personnage
culte en russie irina antonova il est là
donc depuis plus d'un demi siècle à la
tête du musée pouchkine on va la
rencontrer ensemble
en face de la cathédrale saint sauveur
en plein centre de moscou les colonnes
du musée des beaux-arts pouchkine
à l'intérieur la conservatrice irina
antonova est très occupé
voilà en france
je suis journaliste à france télévisions
j'ai compris très heureuse de vous
rencontrer max et voilà comme ça vous
allez me présenter d'autres musées
non je ne vais pas faire ça un petit peu
et à pâte et à
irina est pressée car dans deux jours
elle va offrir au public une
rétrospective exceptionnelle des oeuvres
de picasso
une collection de 280 pièces dont la
plupart viennent de paris
une belle revanche pour un artiste qui
avait été interdite par staline et dont
les oeuvres n'étaient pas revenus en
russie depuis 50 ans
après avoir monté la garde plus d'une
heure en haut du grand escalier
irina accepte de nous rencontrer un
instant
merci nous accueillir malades mentaux
novare on peut aller faire cette petite
interview on sent juste heureux t on y
va vous voulez voir les sculptures mais
on ne donne pas d'ordre à celle qui a
survécu à tous les régimes depuis 1956
regardez manama on voulait s'installer
là non je n'aime pas ça non alors qu'est
ce que vous préférez les gens qu'est ce
que vous aimeriez minute moment cette
école
votre nom laurence a piqué laurence
voilà laurence laurence quand vous avez
débuté ici madame antonova c'était il ya
plus de 50 ans picasso n'était pas très
aimé en russie c'était un art qui
n'était pas appréciée par les régimes
soviétiques je n'en voyais je dois vous
dire que cette grande différence entre
origine il ya des personnes qu'ils
aiment l'art on ne peut pas mêler les
choses c'est vrai mais mes souvenirs on
ne dit pas si on n'a pas aimé on n'a pas
connu on n'a pas la permission de
montrer et pourquoi parce que sa place
était une commande il une loi oui on
décret
qu'il faut faire mais seul mais c'est ça
et donc tous ces chefs-d'oeuvre se sont
retrouvés dans des réserves
je crois que c'est vous qui avez fait la
carrière la plus longue à la tête d'un
musée dont je m'en vais mais rester au
musée pour toute la vie c'était pas
possible pour moi de commencement mais
je pense et je peux travailler ici
quelques années après je peux faire
quelque chose d'autre c'est très
incertain moi je ne pensais pas que j'ai
tardé pour toute ma vie une maryse et
moi j'étais plus plus plus de bandits
plus vous le la mais oui je t'ai et nous
avons fait notre alliance à 47 et sature
jusqu'aujourd'hui
pour
savoir sur
quel est votre regard sur la russie
culturel d'aujourd'hui qui bouge avec
des nouveaux lieux d'exposition savez la
vie est très
maintenant artistique à moscou je dois
dire est très intéressant je vous assure
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de calories des
marges de leurs des peintures même
l'art s'est jamais la quantité seulement
la politique oui j'attends le feu vert
dans la c
c'est l'expression de 10 km ski moi je
ne veux pas mourir sans borne et alors
je suis toujours dans une même moment 2
je cherche vous avez même il y en a deux
peintres pas mal un petit pas mal mais
ce n'est pas ce qui a donné par jean
plus qu'aux
907 quand il a inventé
vous envisagez un jour la retraite
madame antonova
moi non
mais
merci michael va
bien
[Musique]
non
vous connaissez visa mode d'un gagneur
oui bien sûr c'est le centre d'art
contemporain de moscou
vinaphone c'est en fait une ancienne
usine à 20 désaffectée transformée en
lieu d'exposition avec des galeries
c'est là qu'on vient boire un café le
week end à l'immigré est les artistes
contemporains c'est peut-être là qu'on
va découvrir ces fameuses feuilles
vertes dont parlait irina antonova c'est
là qu'on va assister à ce printemps
russe de la création en attendant on
découvre un créateur gotcha qui est très
corrosif très décapants on le retrouve
tout de suite
avant de découvrir bin jawad rendez vous
d'abord dans la banlieue de moscou
c'est jour de messe
la plupart des russes sont très attachés
à l'orthodoxie
[Musique]
coscia est un des artistes les plus
subversives de moscou mais il n'échappe
pas à la tradition
le dimanche il est aussi diacre
chaque artiste est fait uniquement parce
que c'est un image
mois comme artiste quand un parent je
fais les échos d'aujourd'hui je fais les
icônes maintenant le temps de maintenant
je peins longtemps
les icônes de gotcha elle s'inspire du
pop art et des comics vous elle affiche
la violence de la société russe version
post communiste
ces derniers temps c'est derrière
l'église que gotcha nourrit son
inspiration
[Rires]
c'est pas facile
ce moment je travaille sur un scoop sur
le vieux bois avec son histoire passée
qui vient d'église et moi je rajoute au
dessus de traces moderne
gotcha à travailler en france avec jean
paul gaultier il expose dans toute
l'europe à 43 ans c'est un des artistes
les plus réputés de sa génération
domo scouts sont certaine dynamique
parce que c'est ça change tout le temps
elle y est ça inspire bien sûr parce que
tu sens certaine énergie
dans son atelier sa dernière oeuvre
expriment des tensions que gotcha
détecte dans la russie de poutine
en fait c'est un personnage c'est le
thème des conflits entre les
omd fin tu a par exemple toujours
mondial et ford center cette série voilà
il est une femme qui peut qui gueule il
ya une serrure sur le bouche
si c'est un personnage de gouvernement
ça va ce masque de fonctionnaires et de
l'autre côté c'est une femme sur un
symbole un pool qui dans l'énergie et
attire et là un personnage de militaires
qui s'y est de cacher les yeux à cause
de la lumière est bon après c'est chaque
spectateur peut trouver son histoire
dans le nord
à travers sa peinture votre chat lui
dénonce l'absolutisme du pouvoir
politique
[Musique]
le concept ce que ces deux-là pouvoir on
n'a pas ce qu'il y à une signe sur la
les robes en rouge avec le hêtre à hp
aarhus c'est vous dire un nouvel
gouvernement ben ça veut dire c'est le
tout ce qu' on est servi pour le
gouvernement on était comme des esclaves
sexuelles voilà grosso modo je prends le
support de bdc de langage qui tout le
monde comprend et ici c'est un certain
de lute contre le pento classique
les oeuvres de goya se vendent déjà à
londres et à paris
au maintenant
allons enfin si j'avais pris d'accidents
tôt c'est à peu près 25 mille euros
[Musique]
une fois par semaine le mardi gotcha
ouvre son atelier aux autres peintres et
aux collectionneurs
autour de la table on parle d'art de
nouvelles tendances on échange des
concepts des noms et on parle de liberté
d'expression bien sûr
je pense que les artistes sont beaucoup
plus libres à faire ce qu'ils veulent
que n'importe quelle autre
profession libérale
les artistes c'est vrai
les artistes
font pas du terrain comme les avocats ou
les journalistes par exemple
il ya bien des domaines que vous preniez
ne sont pas couchés je passe manquée
police
église
de montrer le sexe
[Musique]
à première vue aucun
moment je pense se comporte comme en
france certains tabous qui
elles mêmes partout
ces dix dernières années la création a
explosé à moscou
les galeries où les rendez vous branchez
se sont multipliées dans des lieux
parfois inattendus
comme ici au look une ancienne usine de
matériel électrique transformée en bar
dédié à l'art moderne
ce que j'adore c'est de la faune très
haute il ya deuxième étage
ça c'est à ces oeuvres aussi
l'ami de tous les textes de tolstoï
pouchkine ou de style skiff de dents
et voilà ça sert et c'est mon travail
c'est une lapin
ce tueur peut dire ça souvent les gens
qui arrivent ici lisa dans ses
sculptures parce que ça lui rappelle de
deux les années 90 où les gens ils
tirent dans la rue c'était vraiment la
guerre dont civile pour diviser le pour
diviser le business c'est entre les
bandits n'ont
actuellement ses villas vote qui tient
le haut de l'affiché à moscou
une ancienne fabrique de vin reconverti
il y a trois ans centre d'art où les
moscovites peuvent découvrir plusieurs
artistes dans un même lieu
si c'est vraiment génial peut-être 6e au
vert
ah oui
c'est extraordinaire
au sous sol les chais de l'ancienne
fabrique à kuyt en ce moment des
installations vidéo
je passe cette vie de m d'eau sa
spectaculaire
petit peu même en un jeu avec lui
des artistes
dans une des trois salles d'exposition
de vizzavona une valeur montante de la
peinture contemporaine russe
dans quelques jours alexei kalima expose
ses nouvelles toiles
[Musique]
alexei 40 ans et russe il est né à
grozny il se revendique artistes
tchétchène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alex émond très molle ce saut en
parachute que je trouve absolument
superbe on sent que c'est vraiment un
thème que qui vous touche 1 qui vous
portent ce saut dans le vide
oui c'est un sujet très intéressant pour
la plastique ça permet de dessiner
l'être humain dans la pesanteur sous
tous les angles alors cette équipe de
femmes parachutistes qui saute au dessus
de la tchétchénie c c'est un souvenir
les baptisés souvenirs implanté c'est
comme si je transplanté dans la réalité
de cette chaîne actuelle cette équipe de
famille imaginaire alors qu'il est
évident que la tchétchénie a d'autres
choses à faire que de s'occuper de chute
libre
en fait c'est une critique nous devrions
tous faire pour essayer de ne pas penser
à la guerre tablettes etc le ch devrions
plutôt penser à de belles choses à la
liberté par exemple
et les filles de tchétchénie devrait
tout sauter en parachute
conquérir le sommet des montagnes faire
du patin à glace mais plutôt que de
courir avec des mitraillettes dans les
mains
ou de se terrer pour fuir toute cette
violence
assez intéressant chez ces oppressions
[Musique]
pour travailler alexei s'est installé au
sein même de vie la bonne ils sont une
dizaine d'artistes comme lui
sculpteurs créateurs de mode ou peintre
acquis le centre a offert un atelier
[Musique]
c'est marrant tu es lièvre à la royale
le bazar
jeu bordel non c'est pas le bordel c'est
très bien rangé je trouve pour un
atelier d'artiste on retrouve au
parachute à ils sont là dans votre
imaginaire et dans votre vie tous les
jours il y en a d'autres encore sur le
thème du parachute ou une peut-être
quinze toiles
des papiers graphiques
bien beau pour mon projet précédent je
dessinais des fans
c'était aussi un travail sur
l'agressivité de la société
ici par exemple c'est un fan de foot qui
se fait tabasser par des flics
c'est une toile qui fait partie de tout
un cycle de peinture
beaucoup de peintres l'art est devenu
très populaire
bien plus populaire que le mal est par
exemple
yves où la situation est vraiment
propice pour moi en ce moment
j'ai des contacts avec la france pour
l'année prochaine par exemple je vais
être en résidence au mac val le musée
d'art contemporain en région parisienne
et y exposer
ensuite je vais participer à une
exposition collective de peintres russes
au louvre
quoi le plus grand défi
moi je sais ce que je veux atteindre
c'est la liberté plastique idéologique
la liberté absolue ensemble
[Musique]
c'est tout
des artistes prometteurs un marché en
pleine expansion en quelques années
moscou est devenu un nouvel eldorado du
commerce de l'art
jo est anglaise elle travaille pour
sotheby's la célèbre maison de vente aux
enchères londonienne
regardez cette voiture c'est incroyable
c'est la nature qui fait de l'art oui
c'est vrai on dirait une sculpture cette
voiture sous la neige
c'est génial
alors que c'est amusant que la voiture
soit blanche on peut à peine faire la
différence avec la neige
attendez je vais vérifier que personne
soit coincé
non c'est bon il ya personne
chaque mois je viens une semaine à
moscou la ville dit on qui concentre le
plus de milliardaires au monde
et en russie tout bon milliardaire se
doit d'avoir un club de foot et une
collection d'art
ce matin zhou a rendez vous avec ambri
l'un de ses clients nord
à 43 ans andreï a fait fortune dans le
pétrole et possède le club de foot du
spartak de moscou est l'une des plus
grandes collections privées de tableau
du 19e
ça c'est l'humilité russe
avant la révolution d'accord mais est ce
assez après les révolutions ça se joue
les ordres tous les arbres j'aime
beaucoup ça et c'est l'histoire de notre
patrie très long l'histoire très bon
l'histoire
d'apple et on habite
la qualité de ce qu'il y ait ici c'est
très haut et pour moi je peux voir
quelque chose de nouveau chaque fois il
allait les
tableaux ici qu'on ne peut pas voir dans
les musées
et que pour mon travail c'est très
important
si l'équipe est mignonne et riches
américains non catholiques et
j'ai déjà acheté je fais
parce que je fais le cadre exclusif avec
laure 24 heures
et c'est pourquoi
les cadres préparée m 2 mois
et dans sa chambre andry a exposé la
toile la plus rare de son peintre
fétiche
d'envoyer au public et des auteurs
divers
pour lui l'oeuvre n'avait pas de prix
nous est venue
commémorer
[Musique]
au château chouette fin de la visite est
reprise des affaires
joey andreï s'isole quelques instants
loin de nos micros
ce soir là en cinq minutes une toile a
sans doute changé de mains mais laquelle
la même façon
andré vous avez conclu quelque chose
aujourd'hui avec john vous avez fait du
business ouais et vous allez vous dire
quoi non c'est une autre
série
mais je suis je suis comme ceux d'hier
heureuse je suis reste chaud s'est passé
quelque chose s'est passé
[Musique]
joe emporte son secret à londres où elle
rentre demain
[Musique]
dernière nuit à moscou
[Applaudissements]
ce soir le musée pouchkine ouvre son
exposition picasso au public
il emmène voir le tableau de
l'exposition absolument magnifique je
voudrais que vous regardiez cette jeune
femme acrobates un sa grâce
sa beauté en train de jouer à la balle
face à cet homme impassible et triste on
est en plein dans la période rose 1905
et picasso vienne quitter la période
bleue et je trouve ce tableau d'une
infinie beauté voilà c'est le tableau
qui à lui seul mérite de venir à moscou
au musée pouchkine
j'espère que vous avez apprécié autant
que moi cette promenade culturelle dans
la capitale russe une capitale qui vit
qui bouillonne avec toutes ses créations
artistiques spassiba la zidane ya à
bientôt